This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. You have the desire to help a real difference? The College, LaCite, you offer the program Dependance and Sentental. Acquare the competences
这是一个I-Heart播客。百分之百真人。你有帮助他人做出真实改变的渴望吗？拉齐特学院为你提供“依赖症与社会关怀”项目。掌握相关技能
essential for accompany and support the people confronted to the health and dependents. Construise a career enriching to service
对于陪伴和支持面临健康和依赖问题的人群至关重要。开启一份丰富充实的职业生涯，服务
of the community francophone of all the country. Don't the quality in French, it's possible
于全国各地的法语社区。无需精通法语，在学院也能实现
with the City. Visit Collage LaC. .A. today, An initiative of the Consortium National
。今天就访问Collage LaC. .A.，这是国家健康培训联盟的一项倡议，由加拿大卫生部支持。那些眼睛里毫无生气。它们变成了黑色。这把我吓坏了。恶魔，醒醒。我是亲眼目睹谋杀案
of Formation in Health Supposed by Santee Canada. There was no anything inside those eyes. They turned black. It scared the hell out of me. Evil, wake up. I'm the woman that saw the murder
在克里瓦奇和德皮波面前发生的那个人。安东尼·德皮波没有表现出丝毫悔意，在被判处最高刑罚时显得无动于衷。我说，我没有罪。我将把这带进坟墓。在iHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听“恶魔采石场：骨头谷之谜”。快乐至关重要，它也同样难以捉摸，但现在有一个全新且令人兴奋的方式来开启你的旅程
take place by Krivac and DePippo. Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum. I said, I'm not guilty. I'll take it to the grief. Listen to the devil's quarry in the Bone Valley feed on the IHeart Radio app. Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Joy is essential and it's also elusive, but now there's a new and exciting way to start your journey
迈向一个更快乐的生活。快乐101。这是一个由我，霍达·科特比主持的全新播客。如果你渴望获得最大化快乐的灵感，请收听这些坦诚、振奋人心且感人的直播聊天。打开你免费的iHeart Radio应用程序。搜索“快乐101”并立即收听。由CVS呈现的《霍达·科特比的快乐101》。
toward a more joyful existence. Joy 101. It's a new podcast hosted by me, Hoda Kotby. If you're craving inspiration to maximize your joy, tune into these candid, uplifting, and moving on-air chats. Open your free IHeart Radio app. Search Joy 101 and listen now. Joy 101 with Hoda Kotfi is presented by CVS.
每个人都把我当成一名足球运动员，但在成为任何其他身份之前，我首先是一个人。自我出生以来，每一天我仍在学习如何与问题、错误、人际关系以及各种情绪共存。这不是一个普通的播客。这里的一切都是即兴的、真实的、发自内心的。这只是关于生存意义的真诚对话。我是哈维尔·奇查里托·奥尔内斯，
Everyone sees me as a football player, but before anything else, I'm human. Every single day I'm still learning how to live with problems, mistakes, relationships, emotions ever since I was born. This isn't a normal podcast. Everything here is spontaneous, real, and genuine. Just honest conversations about what it means to be alive. I'm Javier Chichariot-O-Nand-es,
并收听在iHeart Radio、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方播出的《学习做人》。你的丈夫并不是你所认为的那样。你的身体也不是你以前认为的那样。你的身份由一段秘密历史塑造。我是丹妮·夏皮罗。这些只是我将在《家族秘密》第14季中探索的众多震撼人心故事中的一小部分。
and listen to learning to be human. on IHard Radio, Apple Podcasts, or whatever you get your podcast. Your husband is not who you think he is. Your body is not what you thought it was. Your identity is formed by a secret history. I'm Danny Shapiro. And these are just a few of the stunning stories I'll be exploring on the 14th season of Family Secrets.
他有点把我推开说，让开。然后他走出了前门，跳上一辆车开走了。那是我最后一次见到他。收听《家族秘密》第14季。在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。大家好，我是杰玛·斯派克，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们探讨二十岁时面临的最大改变、时刻和转型，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么。大家好，欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到本播客。
He kind of shoved me out of the way and said, move. And he went out the front door and he jumped in a car and drove off. And that was the last time I saw him. Listen to Season 14 of Family Secrets. secrets on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello, everybody. I'm Jemma Spake, and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s, and what they mean for our psychology. Hello, everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast.
很高兴你能来到这里收听又一期节目，和我们一起剖析二十岁的心理。所以几周前，我在阿姆斯特丹一家二手书店的橱窗里看到了这本书，名叫《迷信心理学》。这就好像，你知道当你看到一本书，它仿佛在呼唤你一样，它当时就在呼唤我。我是一个有着深厚迷信倾向的人，从我还是个孩子的时候就开始了。我立刻买下了它，然后我把这个问题抛给了你们，也就是听众们，问你们是否想听一期关于这个话题的节目，结果你们当中所有人都说，是的，绝对想听。所以，这就是那一期节目。正如我从这本书中了解到的，迷信行为在人类生存过的
It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we break down the psychology. of our 20s. So a few weeks ago, I saw this book in the window at a secondhand bookstore in Amsterdam called The Psychology of Superstition. It was like, you know, when you see a book and it's like calling to you, it was calling to me. I'm a deeply superstitious person, have been since I was a kid. I immediately bought it and I kind of put the question out to you guys, the listeners, asking if you wanted to hear an episode on it and all that you. of you said, yes, absolutely, we do. So this is that episode. Superstitious behaviors, as I learned from this book, show up in basically every single culture across every single time period
基本上每一个单一文化、每一个单一历史时期中都会出现。它们是人类文明结构中一种心照不宣的部分。事实证明，它们比你想象的更具心理学色彩。它们也远不只是为了实际控制结果和创造好运，更多的是关于情绪调节和焦虑管理。当我们进行迷信仪式时，我们的脑海中其实会发生一种极为平静的事情，这是我们可以看到和观察到的。不仅如此，它们还将我们深深地与其他连接在一起。它们会创造出自证预言，因为它们在无意识中影响着我们的行为，它们甚至可能带有一点进化的目的。我们的迷信信仰也有一些负面影响，我们接下来也会讨论到这一点。它们与阴谋论的关系就是其中之一，
that humans have been alive for. They are an unspoken part of the fabric of humanity. And it turns out they are more psychological than you would think. They're also a lot less about actually controlling outcomes and creating good luck and more about emotional regulation and anxiety management. When we perform superstitious rituals, something deeply calming actually occurs in our minds that we can see and we can observe. Not only that, they also connect us deeply to others. They create self-fulfilling prophecies because they unconsciously influence our behavior, and they may even have a little bit of an evolutionary purpose. There are also some downsides to our superstitious beliefs that we're going to talk about as well. Their relationship to conspiracy theories is one of
它们如何与强迫症和焦虑症交织在一起，只是其中另外几个例子。但归根结底，我认为拥有仪式、小迷信、为了在精神上保护自己或帮助自己而进行的日常小习惯，对大多数人来说是一件非常有价值的事情，无论你正处于二十岁还是更年科学表明，相信比你更宏大的事物，实际上可能帮助你过上更成功的生活。因此，根据一些迷信的研究，我们将准确探讨为什么会这样，此外还有一些你可能想尝试的来自世界各地的非常有趣的迷信仪式。废话不多说，让我们切入正题。
them, how they intersect with OCD and anxiety to name a few others. But ultimately, I think having rituals, small superstitions, small practices that you do to mentally protect yourself or help yourself is for most people an incredibly valuable thing to have, whether you're in your 20s and beyond. And the science says it may actually help you live a more successful life to believe in something bigger than you. So we're going to talk about exactly why that is, according to some fascinating research, plus some really interesting superstitious rituals from across the world that you may want to try. Without further ado, let's get into it.
那么，到底什么是迷信呢？因为我觉得你会惊讶地发现，我们日常生活中做的许多事情实际上都有着迷信的起源。因此，迷信通常被定义为任何这样一种信念：某个特定的行动、物品、符号或巧合能够并且将以一种超越寻常因果关系的方式影响结果。换句话说，迷信将客观上毫无关联的事物联系在一起，让它们感觉好像有关联，通常是通过某种神秘的、超自然的、甚至是宗教的、因果报应的力量。一个很好的例子，经典的例子就是在说出你所希望但又不想发生的事情后敲木头，以免带来霉运。无意识地避免
So what is superstition, really? Because I think you'd be surprised how many everyday things we do actually have superstitious origins. So superstition is usually defined as like any belief that a particular action, object, symbol or coincidence can can and will influence outcomes in a way that goes beyond ordinary cause and effect. In other words, superstition links things that are objectively not connected so that they feel connected, often through some mystical, otherworldly, maybe even religious, calmic force. So great example, classic example is like touching wood after saying something you're hoping for that you don't want to happen, so not to jinx things. Unconsciously avoiding
说出诸如“哦，我对此感到兴奋”或“我对此感觉很好”这样的话，如果这件事还没有发生的话，因为那感觉就像你在挑战命运。也许你在每次面试或每个第一天都戴同一副耳环，尽管它们实际上并不能理性地影响结果，但你对它深信不疑。或者你在包里放一个幸运符。你向骰子吹气。你不想踩到裂缝，不在梯子下面走，因为你认为这会给你带来某种诅咒。这些客观上与迷信结果无关，但我们仍然会做的事。这些微小的仪式起初可能看起来非常微不足道，甚至微不足道到不值一提，但你还是会做。你会发现自己不由自主地敲木头，
saying like, oh, I feel excited or I feel good about this thing if it hasn't had. happened yet because that feels like your tempting fate. Maybe you wear the same earrings to every job interview or every first day, even though they don't actually rationally influence the outcome, you're superstitious about it. Or you keep a lucky charm in your bag. You blow on dice. You don't want to step on the cracks, not walking under ladders because you think it's going to kind of curse you. Things that are objectively not related to the superstitious outcome, but that we still do. And these tiny rituals that might initially seem really insignificant, so much so that they don't even count for anything, but you still do them. You still involuntarily find yourself knocking on wood,
不从梯子下走过，看到黑猫时念祈祷文。这里有一个名为“半信信”的概念，它首次发表于2024年的一篇论文中。它探讨了为什么许多人，可能就像你一样，会实践迷信的事情或践行迷信，尽管他们并不相信这些，因为这些观念已经深深编织进人类的历史和意识之中。在这篇论文中，通过对两组参与者的调查，近一半的参与者践行了某种迷信信念或行为，尽管他们大多数人并不确信它是真实存在的。因此，当被问及“你认为这真的有什么用吗”时，大多数人会说没有，但他们还是这么做了。即使从理性上讲，我们不
not walking under ladders, saying a prayer when you see a black cat. So there's this concept called half belief that was first spoken about in a paper published in 2024. And it talks about how many people, probably like you, practice superstitious things or practice superstitions, even though they don't believe in them, because of how woven they are into human history and consciousness. In this paper across two samples of participants, nearly half of these participants practiced some kind of superstitious belief or behavior, even though the majority of them was not convinced that it was actually real. So when they were asked, do you think this actually does anything, most of them would say no, but they still did it anyway. Even if rationally we don't
相信或没有证据证明这些事情有效，但迷信行为再次表明，这是一种深度重复出现的人类现象，构成了我们集体意识的一部分。当你审视一些最古老、最重要的迷信时，我们就能看出为什么它们在心理学上如此重要，因此得以留存如此之久。以驱邪眼（Evil Eye）为例。这其实是一个拥有五千年历史的迷信，起源于美索不达米亚和地中海地区，其核心在于，当人们对你感到嫉妒或羡慕时，这实际上会损害你的好运。因此，通过佩戴驱邪眼护身符——我相信你现在到处都能看到它，通过展示那个蓝色眼睛的饰物，这几乎可以反转
believe or don't have evidence that these things work, superstitious behaviors, again, are a deeply reoccurring human event that are part of our collective consciousness. When you look at some of the oldest, most significant superstitions, that is when we can kind of see why they are so psychologically significant and therefore have survived for so long. Take, for example, displaying the evil eye. This is actually a 5,000-year-old superstition originating in like Mesopotonia, in the Mediterranean, and it basically says that when people are jealous or envious of you, this can actually poison our own good fortune. So by wearing an evil eye amulet, which I'm sure you see everywhere these days, by displaying that blue eye charm, this almost reversed.
就像把诅咒反弹回那个对你抱有负面想法的人身上，并用他们自己的嫉妒之心将他们击倒。如今，到处都是，每一家珠宝店，每一个，就像，每个女孩都有一条这样的项链。但人类学研究表明，人们展示某种版本的驱邪眼已有数千年历史，从他们在埃及和希腊发现的这些护身符开始，这种信仰通过如此多的代际流传下来，因为它与社会心理学的许多方面相契合，即嫉妒和社会威胁等因素对我们的生存一直都很重要。因此，我们借用符号作为保护，来管理我们在心理上对那些可能希望我们受到伤害的人所感受到的脆弱感。
versus like the curse back on the person who is thinking negatively about you and kind of strikes them down with their own envious thoughts. Nowadays, everywhere, every jewelry shop, every, like, every girl has one of these necklaces. But anthropological works suggest that people have been displaying some version of the evil eye, of this evil eye, for thousands of years, beginning with these amulets that they were finding in Egypt and in Greece, this belief has been passed down through so many generations because it maps onto a lot of aspects of social psychology, in that things like envy and things like social threat have always mattered for our survival. So we employ the use of symbols as protection to manage the sense of vulnerability
第二个例子是“黑色星期五”（13号星期五），这是关于迷信为何以及如何产生的另一种解释。它的起源非常错综复杂。它就像是一个由宗教、神话和历史事件交织而成的神话。我认为，13号星期五可能是一个受诅咒日子的最初概念，源于“最后的晚餐”，犹大是最后晚餐的第13位客人。它发生在，我想是在13号星期五。我其实并不清楚。那是最初的迹象，让我觉得这个日子可能会被诅咒。其他作家将数字13与北欧神话联系起来，特别是洛基作为不受欢迎的额外客人到来，带来混乱和死亡的故事。从历史上看，这种解释很难确凿考证。人们认为星期五
that we have psychologically around people who may wish us harm. The second example is Friday the 13th, and this is another explanation for why and how superstitions come to be. The origin of this is very tangled. It's like a myth of religious, mythological, historical events. The first, I think, notion that Friday the 13th might be a bit of a cursed date was because of the Last Supper, Judas, was the 13th guest at the last supper. It occurred on the, I think on Friday the 13th. I don't really know. That was like the first, I guess, inclination that like this date might be cursed. Other writers have linked 13 to Norse mythology, particularly the story of Loki, arriving as an unwelcome extra guest, bringing chaos and death. That explanation is historically a little bit harder to pin down. Another reason why people think Friday
13可能是个受诅咒的日子，另一个原因是历史上曾发生过许多在这个日子发生的事件。是的，当然还有耶稣受难，但也包括许多看似互不相联、毫无关联的随机事件，唯一的共同点就是它们都发生在这一天。白金汉宫曾发生过一起非常著名的爆炸案，正好落在13号星期五。许多重要人物的逝世都发生在13号星期五。这展示了迷信产生的第二种方式：通过重复，通过一层又一层的故事和历史，随着时间的推移，纯粹由于重复的联想而创造出迷信。解释迷信信念产生的最后一种方式的另一个例子是敲
the 13th maybe a cursed date is because of there's been a lot of the occasions and historical events that have happened on this date. Yes, also obviously the crucifixion, but also a number of just like random things that don't seem interconnected or relevant to each other except for that they all shared this day. So there was a very famous bombing of Buckingham Palace that fell on Friday the 13th. The death of many significant figures has happened on Friday the 13th. This shows the second way that, you know, superstitions come to be through repetition, through layers and layers of stories and history that over time create superstition purely because of repeated association. Another example that explains the final way that superstitious beliefs come to be is knocking
木头，这是我发现自己经常不由自主在做的一个动作。最常见的理论之一将其追溯到古代异教信仰，特别是欧洲的部分地区，当时人们认为树木里住着灵魂、神灵、具有保护作用的超自然力量。在这种观点下，当你触摸一树木，或者后来仅仅是木头本身时，就像是你寻求保护、表达敬意的一种方式，或者默默呼唤这些力量来寻求帮助。它也可能源于一个名为“蒂基蒂基摸木头”（Tiki Tiki Touchwood）的儿童游戏，在这个游戏中，当你摸到一块木头时，你就可以免于被抓，免于成为“抓人者”。我们在澳大利亚也有这样一个游戏，叫做“大本营”（Home Base），我想大概就是当你摸到
on wood, which is one that I find myself unconsciously doing all the time. One of the most common theories links it back to ancient pagan beliefs, particularly in part of Europe, where trees were kind of thought to house spirits, gods, protective, supernatural forces. In that view, when you touch a tree or later just wood itself, it was like your way of asking for protection and showing reverence or, like, quietly calling on those forces for help. It may have also come from a child's game called Tiki Tiki Touchwood, where when you touch a piece of wood, you'd be safe from capture, you'd be safe from being. it. We have a game like this in Australia called Home Base where I guess like when you touch the
木桩时，守卫正在保护你，就像你赢了游戏一样。木桩旁边或木桩中心区域有一个守卫，每个人都在四处奔跑试图到达那里。在这集节目之前，我完全不知道这个传统的来源。然而，每当我说了什么好事、许下愿望、表达渴望，甚至当我说了什么可能发生却不希望发生的坏事时，我都会敲敲木头。这正说明，随着时间的推移，即便古老的宗教或神话信仰逐渐消亡，不再是我们必然被教导的内容，这种行为依然保留了下来。它已经被吸收进我们日常的群体思维中。这三种途径解释了迷信如何成为全球现象或
stump of wood, the guard is protecting like you win the game. Like there's a guard next to a stump of wood or a center piece of wood and everybody's running around trying to get it. Before this episode, I had absolutely no idea that that's where this tradition comes from. Yet every time I say something good or a wish or a desire or even when I say something bad that could happen and I don't want it to happen, I touch wood. And this just goes to show that over time, even as older religious or mythological beliefs die down and aren't necessarily something that we've been taught, the behavior still remains. It's been absorbed into our everyday group thinking. And those are three of the kind of ways that superstitions become global phenomena or become communal
群体现象。重大的心理学问题是：为什么？为什么有些看似随机的事物会变成迷信，而另一些则不会？比如，为什么我们敲木头而不是敲玻璃？为什么即便没有确凿证据，或者正反证据同样充分，我们的大脑也会随机觉得某些事物能带来安慰？迷信背后最大的因素之一是模式识别。迷信的产生往往非常随机，比如某人展示了驱邪眼碰巧迎来了繁荣；某人敲了木头便得到了保护，也许纯粹只是巧合。
phenomena. The big psychological question is why? Why do some things become superstitions that are seemingly random and others don't? Like why do we knock wood and knock glass? Why do our brains randomly find certain things comforting even if there is no solid evidence to them or just as much evidence for one thing over the other? One of the biggest factors behind superstition is pattern recognition. superstitions often begin just really randomly with a kind of like a few examples of where, you know, someone has displayed the evil eye and happened to experience prosperity. Someone has knocked on wood and has been protected maybe just out of coincidence.
人们开始注意到并把这些巧合拼凑在一起。正是这一点，赋予了原本看似随机的事物某种关联和意义。我们的大脑只会看到那些证实我们信念或迷信的例子，而忽略那些不符合的例子，因为这种模式太令人安心了，它创造了秩序。人类的大脑生来就是为了预测接下来会发生什么以保护我们，它们不断试图连接事件、推断原因、检测规律，以兑现这一机制或满足这种愿望。大多数时候，这是很有用的。它帮助我们了解什么影响会带来什么结果。
People start noticing and putting together these coincidences. And that's what gives what are seemingly random things an association and a significant. our brain only then sees the examples that confirm our beliefs or confirm our superstitions, ignoring the ones that don't, because the pattern is so comforting, it creates order. Human brains are built to predict what will happen next in order to protect us, and they are constantly trying to connect events, infer causes, detect regularities, to live up to that mechanism or to fulfill that desire. Most of the time that is useful. It helps us to learn what effects have what outcomes.
但这也意味着，仅仅出于我们对安全、可预测性和安全感的需求，我们很容易在往往完全随机的事物中发现模式。德克萨斯大学的研究人员在2008年发表的一篇相当古老的论文发现，当人们感到缺乏控制时，正是他们最有可能感知到虚幻模式的时候，这包括倾向于阴谋论或迷信思维。当事情感觉混乱、不确定、令人恐惧时，这篇论文表明，大脑通常更倾向于拥有任何解释，哪怕它没有证据，哪怕它无法完全合理解释为什么两件事会联系在一起。
But it also means that we are vulnerable to finding patterns in often complete randomness, just because our need for safety, predictability, security demanded of us. A rather old paper from 2008 from researchers at the University of Texas found that when people felt a lack of control, That is when they were more likely to perceive illusory patterns, which included leaning into conspiracies or leaning into superstitious thinking. When things feel confusing, uncertain, scary, this paper showed that the brain often prefers having any explanation, even if it doesn't have evidence for it, even if it cannot fully rationally explain why two things are linked.
它只需要抓住点什么。同样的逻辑也出现在关于“错觉控制”的研究中。格里菲斯（Griffiths）及其同事在他们的论文中发现，迷信信念更强的人，在实际上由机率决定的情境中，也表现出更强的控制感。这意味着，在模棱两可的环境中，某些人更有可能过分强调他们所做过的某些行为的重要性。由于他们的迷信，他们认为自己处于更核心的地位。护身符、仪式、一句话、特定的座位选择、特定的天使数字。这些开始变得有意义，因为大脑正试图减少模糊性，让我们
it just needs something to grab onto. That same logic appears in research on illusory control. Griffiths and colleagues in their paper found that people with stronger superstitious beliefs also showed stronger perceptions of control in situations that were actually determined by chance. So what this means is that in ambiguous settings, some people are more likely to over-emphasize the fact that certain behaviors they've done mattered. They see themselves as more central because of their superstitions. A charm, a ritual, a phrase, a certain seat choice, a certain angel number. It starts to feel meaningful because the mind is attempting to reduce ambiguity to make us
内心感到安全。这也是“直觉”发挥作用的地方。有时，迷信更多地表现为一种感觉或感受，比如我们感受到的一点点紧张，或者某种情况不对劲的感觉，亦或是被某种选择吸引的感觉。迷信给人的感觉更像是这样。倾听这些感觉使我们变得迷信，而不是靠具体的仪式。直觉之所以产生，是因为大脑在意识觉察之下不断扫描模式，比如这些模式。我们从很多期节目中都知道这一点，我们也讨论过。它接收了大量的信息。我们无法同时刻意思考所有这些。过去的经验、情感记忆、
feel internally safe. This is also where gut feelings come in. Sometimes superstitions arrive more so as sensations or feelings, kind of like a bit of tension that we feel or a sense that something is off or a pull towards a certain choice. It feels, superstition feels more like that. Listening to those things is what makes us superstitious rather than specific rituals. Gut feelings happen because the brain is constantly scanning for patterns beneath conscious awareness, such as these ones. We know this from so many episodes we've talked about it in. It takes in so much information. We cannot deliberately think about it all in once. Past experiences, emotional memories,
微妙的环境线索、微观社交信号、身体感觉。我们实在无法同时思考所有这些。因此，它把所有这些压缩成一种可能成为直觉的单一感觉。有时这种感觉确实很有用。它能反映真正的学习。比如，当我们看到某人脸上露出一丝短暂的表情时。由于过去的经验，我们记得，啊，过去背叛过我们的人曾有过类似的表情。因此，即便他们真实的意图并非昭然若揭，我们也会产生一种直觉，觉得有些不对劲，这是一种有用的情境或有用的线索。但在不确定、压力、恐惧的情况下，这个系统可能会变得过度敏感。大脑开始尝试
subtle environmental cues, microsocial signals, bodily feelings. We just can't think about it at the same time. And so it compresses all of that into a singular feeling that may be a gut instinct. Sometimes that feeling is genuinely useful. It can reflect real learning. Like, when we see a, I don't know, a slight momentary look on someone's face. And because of past experiences, we remember that, ha, the person who betrayed us in the past once had a similar look. And so even if their true intentions are overtly obvious, we get a gut feeling that something's amiss, that's a helpful situation or that's a helpful cue. But in situations of uncertainty, stress, fear, that same system can become oversensitive. The brain starts trying to
保护我们，不仅免受像那个可疑的人这样的真实危险，还要免受模糊感本身的侵害。如果你感到焦虑，这种感觉会增加一百倍，甚至一百万倍，因为你对不确定性已经有了一种非常生理性的反应，无论是否真的有什么不对劲。仅仅因为你的焦虑向各个方向射击，你每天就已经感受到了上百万种直觉。当再加上迷信时，我们可能会做出一些错误的判断。
protect us not just from real danger like that shady person, but just from the sense of ambiguity itself. This is increased 100, if not a million fold, if you are anxious, because you already have a certain response to uncertainty that feels very physical, regardless of whether something is actually wrong. You already feel a million gut feelings every day just because of your anxiety that's shooting in many directions. When superstition is added in, we can make some incorrect calls. all in the name of trying to predict an outcome, trying to keep ourselves really safe. And I think that helps explain why superstitions can feel so compelling. Even when rationally, again, rationally, we know that these two things are probably not linked.
这一切都是为了试图预测结果，试图确保我们真正的安全。我认为这有助于解释为什么迷信会如此具有说服力。即使在理性上，再次强调，在理性上，我们知道这两者可能并没有联系。在车里放一只兔子的脚和能够安全驾驶，这些事情在理性上是没有联系的。意识可能知道，但我们心灵的另一部分却说，也许它们并非毫无联系。虽然没有证据，但为什么要冒险呢？从进化的角度来看，对可能的危险做出过度反应，要比忽视某些可能重要或可能保护我们的事情更安全、而且现在依然如此。迷信就在那种空间中滋生。它们在直觉和不确定性之间的空间中滋生，在那里，大脑再次宁愿做一些象征性的事情，或者它认为可能会有帮助的事情，也不愿被动地坐着，一无所知，什么也做不了。在不确定时刻，我们唯一能做的就是等待和观察，或者我们可以尝试这个酷炫的
Having a rabbit's foot in your car and being able to drive safe, like those things are rationally not linked. The conscious mind probably knows, but another part of our mind says maybe they're not linked. there's no evidence, but why risk it? From an evolutionary perspective, it was and is still safer to overreact to possible danger than to ignore something that might matter or might protect us. Superstitions grow in that space. They grow in that space between intuition and uncertainty where, again, the brain would rather do something symbolic or that it thinks might help than sit passively, not knowing and not being able to do anything. The only thing our can do in moments of uncertainty is just to kind of wait and see, or we can try out this cool
小仪式。早在1994年发表的一篇颇具影响力的论文发现，在高度压力条件下，尤其是在对不确定性容忍度较低的人群中，神奇思维会增加。研究人员要求，我想大约是174名参与者，基本上完成关于神奇思维和对模糊性不宽容的问卷调查。顺便说一句，这些人当时都生活在海湾战争时期的战区，他们要么经常遭受导弹袭击（属于高压力条件），要么没有遭受袭击（属于低压力条件）。研究发现，处于高压力条件下、基本上正积极生活在战区中的参与者，与那些没有经历过的人相比，更有可能参与神奇思维。因为在这些
little ritual. A pretty notable paper from back in 1994 found that magical thinking increases under high stress conditions, especially among people with lower tolerance of uncertainty. Researchers asked, I think it was like 174 participants to basically complete questionnaires about magical thinking and intolerance to ambiguity. All of these people, by the way, were living in war zones during the Gulf War and they were either exposed to regular missile strikes, so that was a high stress condition or not exposed, low stress condition. What the research has found was that participants in the high stress condition who were actively living in a war zone, basically, were more likely to engage in magical thinking compared to those who weren't. Because under these
几乎无法控制的局势下，他们无法确定炸弹或导弹会落在哪里，哪里不会落。他们无法控制既定的政治力量，心灵唯一能触及的就是象征性控制以及这些迷信信念——即做某些事情可能会保护他们，不做某些事情可能会让他们面临危险。这是一个非常重要的观点。正如这个例子所示，迷信通常关乎恐惧管理。心理学研究证明，微小的行动可以调节情绪，恰恰是因为它们微小，因为它们切实可行。而这种仪式化的行为可以抵消我们对更大事情的焦虑。这些仪式化的四叶草、敲木头、驱邪眼行为在
situations where so little was in their control, they couldn't determine where a bomb or where a missile was going to drop and where it wasn't. They weren't in control of the political forces that be the only thing the mind could reach for was symbolic control and was these superstitious beliefs that doing certain things might protect them, not doing certain things might leave them at risk. This is such an important point. Superstition is often about fear management as this example shows. Psychological research proves that tiny actions regulate emotions precisely because they are tiny, because they are doable. And this ritualized behavior can counteract our anxieties about bigger things. These ritualized four-leaf clover, knock-on wood, evil eye behaviors are powerful in that
这种方式下非常强大。哈佛大学的研究人员在2016年的一篇论文中进一步证明了这一点，他们让参与者参与仪式——即一系列非常重复、非常正式的象征性动作，当他们在压力任务前这样做时，实际上提高了他们的表现。这表明了一件非常重要的事情。迷信是一种情绪调节的形式。展示驱邪眼、敲木头可能并不能真正改变你的运势，但它能改变你的情绪状态，让你感觉更有掌控力。这实际上才是影响结果的因素。因为一个更冷静的人也能进行理性思考，能更好地解决问题，从而获得更好的结果。这就是迷信信念的力量。那么，迷信真的能
manner. Researchers from Harvard actually demonstrated this further in a 2016 paper where they got basically participants who engaged in rituals, so a sequence of symbolic actions that were very repetitive, very formal, when they did this before stressful tasks, it actually improved their performance. This goes to show something very important. Superstition is a form of emotional regulation. Displaying the evil lie, knocking on wood, may not actually change your luck, but it changes your emotional state to feel more in control. That is actually what influences the outcome. Because somebody who is calmer can also think rationally, can problem solve better, will have a better outcome. That is the power of the superstitious belief. So do superstitions
改变结果吗？答案是：有时会，但并非以你预期的那种方式。短暂停顿之后，我们将讨论所有这些以及更多内容。在蒙特利尔市中心的Residences连住四晚，搭乘波特航空公司的航班，两张周末黄金门票，还有1000加元的现金。请尽情享受吧。Lord、扎拉·拉尔森、戴夫·麦克雷、Sombor、21飞行员乐队等等。下载iHeart Radio，收听iHeart新音乐10分钟，即可参与抽奖。Oceaga，2026年。你收听的每一天都是又一次获胜的机会。
actually change outcomes? The answer is sometimes yes, but not in the way that you would expect. We're going to discuss all of that and more after this short break. With four nights at residents in downtown Montreal, flights from Porter Airlines, two weekend gold tickets, and $1,000 of cash. Please love it. Lord, Zara Larson, Dave McRae, Sombor, 21 pilots, and more. Download I-Heart Radio, listen to I-Heart new music for 10 minutes, and enter to win. Oceaga, 2026. Every day you listen is another chance to win.
那一刻，感觉仿佛过了一个世纪。我以为自己活不成了。我吓坏了。那些眼睛里毫无生气。它们变成了黑色。这把我吓坏了。那是你的第一起谋杀案？是的，长官。
In the moment, it felt like it was going on forever. I didn't think I was going to live. I was terrified. There was no anything inside those eyes. They turned black. It scared the hell out of me. That was your first murder case? Yes, sir.
可以说这是你职业生涯中最大的一起案件吗？是的，长官。针对儿童的强奸和谋杀。罪大恶极。我想是的。人们醒醒。我才是那个看到谋杀
Fear to say this was the biggest case of your career? Yes, sir. Rape and murder for a child. Just as bad as it gets. I would think so. People wake up. I'm the one that saw them. murder take place by crevette and de pippo.
由克里瓦奇和德皮波实施的人。安东尼·德皮波没有表现出丝毫悔意，在被判处最高刑罚时显得无动于衷。我说，我没有罪。我将把这带进坟墓。在iHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《恶魔采石场》。要在苹果播客上无广告并收听独家内容的《恶魔采石场》，请订阅LaVa for Good Plus。嘿，我是霍达·科特比，播客《霍达·科特比的快乐101》的主持人。在这里，我们将与世界上最迷人的人物进行有意义的对话。比如当女演员奥利维娅·穆恩分享她如何克服严峻的健康挑战时。我曾经历过乳腺癌，然后又帮助母亲度过乳腺癌，那更加艰难。
Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse, appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum. I said, I'm not guilty. I'll take it to the grief. Listen to the devil's quarry on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. And to hear the Devil's Quarry ad free with exclusive content, subscribe to LaVa for Good Plus on Apple Podcasts. Hey, I'm Hoda Kotby, host of the podcast, Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby. Together, we're going to have meaningful conversations with the world's most fascinating people. Like when actress Olivia Munn shared how she overcame fierce health challenges. I've gone through breast cancer and then helped my mother through breast cancer, and that was more difficult.
有很多人理解产后抑郁。但我对产后焦虑毫无准备。在iHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的任何地方收听《霍达·科特比的快乐101》。这真是太令人兴奋了，因为他们的全新明星
There's a lot of people who understand postpartner depression. I was not prepared for postpartum anxiety. Listen to Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. And it's a ton of exciting because their new star
是哈维尔·奇查里托·埃尔南德斯。他来自墨西哥，他会全力以赴。每个人都把我当成足球
is Javier Cichorito Hernandez. He's from Mexico he's going to push it. Everyone sees me as a football
运动员，但在成为任何其他身份之前，我首先是一个人。自我出生以来，每一天我仍在学习如何与问题、
player, but before anything else, I'm human. Every single day I'm still learning how to live with problems,
错误、人际关系以及各种情绪共存。我依然有这么多的疑问。我们从哪里来？
mistakes, relationships, emotions ever since I was born. And I still have so many questions. Where do we come from?
死后会发生什么？你如何应对被取消？C罗还是梅西？外星人存在吗？什么是爱？皇家马德里还是巴萨？
What happens after death? How do you deal with cancellation? Cristiano or Messi? Do aliens exist? What is love? Real Madrid or Varsa?
从日常与平凡到深邃与非凡。这不是一个普通的播客。这里的一切都是即兴的、真实的、发自内心的。这个播客就像与你最亲密的朋友进行的一次深入交谈，脆弱感在这里流露。阴谋论被摆上台面，目标和人生教训得以分享。生命中的一切都有着完美的秩序，一切皆是公正。
From every day and ordinary to the deep and extraordinary. This isn't a normal podcast. Everything here is spontaneous, real and genuine. This podcast is like a deep talk with your closest friends, where vulnerability comes out. Conspiracy theories end up on the table, and goals and lessons are shared. All in this life has an order perfect and everything is just.
等等，我，我将会能够。我们在此为了连接。奇查里托。我是哈维尔·埃尔·奇查里托·奥尔内斯，与Ica Radio一起，我们将让平凡变得非凡。保持关注。在iHeart Radio、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《学习做人》。
Wait, me, I'm going to be able to be able to be. We are here to connect. The Chicharito. I'm Javier El Chicharito-Randes, and together with Ica Radio, we're going to make the ordinary, extraordinary. Stay close. Listen to learning to be human on IHard Radio, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast.
主流媒体充斥着对无家可归者的粗俗刻板印象，那些充满羞耻、指责并将无家可归者描绘成单一群体的故事。“我们，无家可归者”是一档正在改变这一现状的播客。我是西奥·亨德森，节目的创作者兼主持人，多年来我创造了一个空间，让无家可归者及其倡导者能够讲述他们自己的故事。仅在过去的几个月里，我就采访过无家可归的父母、移民、守望相助组织者、退伍军人、LGBTQIA+社群，以及那些制定影响无家可归者生存状态的法律的政策制定者。“我们，无家可归者”是一档荣获韦比奖和信号奖两项大奖的节目，未来还将迎来许多令人兴奋的嘉宾。本周请收听我对吉奥医生的采访，她是一位由街头医生转型为网红的医生，她在无家可归者社群中的工作在网络和她的社群中产生了巨大的
Mainstream media is full of crude depictions of the unhoused, stories that shame and blame and paint the unhoused as a monolith. We The UnHouse is the podcast that's changing that. I'm Theo Henderson, creator and host, and for years I've created a space where the unhoused and their advocates can tell their own stories. In the last few months alone, I've interviewed unhoused parents, immigrants, mutual aid organizers, veterans, the LGBTQTIA plus community, and the policymakers who make the laws that impact the unhoused existence. Whedian Houses a two-time Webby and Signal Award-winning show with many exciting guests on the horizon. Tune in this week for my interview with Dr. Gio which are a street doctor turned influencer whose work with the unhoused community has made a huge
影响。在iHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的节目中收听“我们，无家可归者”。迷信的人，我认为经常会受到不公正的负面评价，正如我们探讨过他们为什么会发展出这些仪式一样，我自己就是其中一员，我认为我们因不够理性而被贴上标签，被认为有点神神叨叨，或者也许不是最聪明的人，或者只是那些希望并需要任何东西来让自己感觉好一点的焦虑人群。我认为这是一种过于简单化的视角，它忽视了关于人类心理和人类行为的一些非常深刻的事实。是的，从某种意义上说，相信没有证据基础的事物是不理性的。但这并不像我刚刚在
impact online and in her community listen to weelian housed on the iHeard radio app apple podcast or wherever you get your podcast superstitious people i think often get a bad rap like we've explored why they come to develop these rituals me being one of those people i think we get a bad rap for being irrational and for being a little bit woo-woo or maybe not the sharpest tools in the shed or being just anxious people who want and need anything to make us feel better. I think that is a way too simplistic perspective and it overlooks some very deep, deep facts about human psychology and human behavior. Yes, in a sense, it is irrational to believe in something that's not evidence-based. But that doesn't mean that rituals do nothing. As I said right before
这次休息前所说的那样，意味着仪式毫无用处。它们确实可以、也将继续产生一种自证预言的效果。具体方式如下。科隆大学的研究人员在2010年发表了一篇被广泛引用的论文，发现参与某种好运迷信可以提高涉及运动技能、记忆力和毅力的任务的表现。部分原因在于，你知道，进行或执行迷信仪式增强了个人自我效能感，即他们相信自己能够执行改变结果所需的行为。幸运符、这种行为、这个仪式让他们更加平静，并赋予了他们尝试某些事情（甚至是任何事情）的信心，而在此之前的情境中，恐惧只会让他们什么都不做。而这种能力，或者仅仅是
this break, they do and can and will continue to create a bit of a self-fulfilling prophecy effect. And here is how. There is a heavily cited paper from researchers at the University of Cologne published in 2010 that found engaging in some kind of good luck superstition, improved performance on tasks involving motor skills, memory, and persistence. In part, because you know, doing or performing a superstitious ritual increased an individual self-efficacy, i.e. their belief that they could execute the behaviors necessary to change the outcome themselves. The lucky charm, the behavior, the ritual made them calmer and gave them confidence to try something, anything, compared to a previous situation where fear made them do nothing. And that ability or just,
朝着做某事发生的轻微路线转变，正是改变结果的关键。我认为这有点像孩子们带自己最喜欢的毛绒玩具去学校。你还记得当你还是个孩子的时候，在入学的头几周你可以带上玩具来帮助我们适应吗？这个玩具并没有改变环境的任何部分，除了它让人感到更舒适，并且玩具所具有的积极联想引发了心理效应，从而改善了我们的情绪，提升了我们的情感，让我们觉得自己能够应对。这有助于解释为什么运动员、表演者、音乐家在面对高
that slight course change towards doing something, that is. what changed the outcome. I think it's kind of like when children bring their favorite stuff toy to school with them. Do you remember that when you were a kid in the first couple weeks you got to bring your toy to help us like settle in? The toy doesn't change anything about the environment apart from the fact that it makes it more comfortable and the positive associations the toy has induces a psychological effect in that it improves our mood and improves our emotions and makes us feel like we can cope. This helps, explain why athletes, performers, musicians, so often develop superstitions and rituals in high
压领域时，如此频繁地发展出迷信和仪式。不确定性无处不在。你可以训练多年，却依然会遇到状态不佳的一天、奇怪的感觉、大脑一片空白，或者遭遇别人向你扔东西、对你大喊大叫。人们在表演周围建立常规，相同的热身、相同的饮食、相同的播放列表、相同的袜子、相同的行为顺序。因为，无论是有意识还是无意识，这都有助于他们管理事情可能出错的焦虑。这有助于他们对那些自己无法控制的事物产生更多的掌控感。仪式与其说是关于运气。我认为这是我们首先想到的。
pressure domains, uncertainties everywhere. You can train for years and still have an off day, still have a weird feeling, still blank, still have somebody throw something at you, yell at you, people create routines around their performances, the same warm up, the same meal, the same playlist, the same socks, the same sequence of things. Because, consciously or even consciously, it helps them manage the anxiety that things could go wrong. It helps them feel more in control of things that they're not in control of. The ritual is less about luck. I think that's the first thing we think.
我们以为这改变了某个人的运气，或者他们以为这改变了他们的运气。不，这更多是关于跨越这个重要的心理门槛。它告诉身体，告诉心灵我们是安全的，我们已经尽了所能，并让他们进入了一种表演状态。让他们为这个盛大的时刻感到准备就绪并一切尽在掌控。迷信还有一个社会层面的意义，我认为人们常常低估了这一点。当你剖析许多迷信和仪式时，它们其实是文化传承下来的。它们是与家庭、传统、祖先保持联系的方式，让我们在面对极其艰难的困境时也能感到
We think that it's changing somebody's luck or they think it's changing their luck. No, it's more about crossing this important mental threshold. It tells the body, it tells the mind that we're safe, we've done everything we can, and it enters them into a performance state. makes them feel prepared and in control for this big moment. There is also a social layer to superstition that I think people often underestimate. So many superstitions and rituals when you break it down are culturally inherited. They are ways of staying connected to family, heritage, ancestors in a way that makes us feel
得到支持。例如，在中国，数字“8”和红色被认为非常非常幸运，被视为能够带来财富和幸福的象征。这是一种全文化范围的迷信。它也深深地与商业、日常生活和重大庆典联系在一起。我其实认为，迷信的一个巨大作用以及人们为什么会迷信，是因为它关乎归属感。仪式可以增强社会认同感和凝聚力。这种感觉即我们所有人被一种比我们自身更宏大的事物凝聚在一起，并受到其引导或支持。关于仪式的研究，尤其是对社区内迷信仪式参与的研究，
supported, even in really hard situations. For example, in China, the number eight, the color red, considered very very important. lucky, considered a symbol that's going to bring wealth and happiness. This is a cultural-wide superstition. It's also deeply tied to business, to daily life, to significant celebrations. And I actually think a big role of superstition and why people are superstitious is because it's about belonging. Rituals can strengthen social identity and cohesion. And this sense that we are all held together in being guided or supported by something larger than ourselves. Studies on rituals, and particularly participation in superstitious rituals within a community,
将仪式的参与同增强的社会纽带、提升的社会幸福感以及更高的个人满意度联系在了一起，尤其是在那些通过共同实践来标志身份和相互关怀的社区中。想想看。在考试、比赛或求职面试中，谁会表现得更好？是一个觉得自己有所归属、有人相信他们、有人默默鼓励他们，并且拥有将他们与这些人连接起来的迷信的人，
have linked ritual engagement with increased social bonding, increased social well-being, and increased individual satisfaction, especially in communities where shared practices signal identity and mutual care. Think about it. Who is going to perform better during an exam or a game or a job interview? Someone who feels like they belong and have people believing in them, silently encouraging them, who has a superstition that connects them to those people,
还是一个感受到独自前行重担、没有任何东西能与自己社区建立联系的人？对我们大多数人来说，这是一个常识性的答案。所以再次强调，这就是为什么迷信在心理学上如此有效。它们让我们感到有掌控力。它们在无意识中为我们管理情绪状态。它们构成了焦虑管理的一种形式。并且它们将我们与比我们自身更宏大的事物连接在一起。
or someone who feels the burden of going at it alone and who has nothing to relate to their community through. I think it's a common sense answer for most of us. So again, this is why superstitions are so effective psychologically. They make us feeling control. They unconsciously manage our emotional state for us. They have a form of anxiety management. And they connect us to something bigger than ourselves.
或者那些独自前行、感到重担在肩、且没有什么能与社区产生共鸣的人。我认为这对我们大多数人来说是一个常识性的答案。所以再说一次，这就是为什么迷信在心理上如此有效。它们让我们感到掌控感。它们在潜意识中为我们管理情绪状态。它们是一种焦虑管理的形式。并且它们将我们与比自身更伟大的事物连接起来。
That is, again, very calming. Is there a downside? Yes, of course there is. There always is. Firstly, the biggest downside of superstitions that we need to talk about, the same thing that pushes people towards superstitions during uncertain times is also what drives people towards conspiracies. Conspiracies are a similar form of what psychologists call compensatory control. When things feel unsafe, we want an explanation and we want someone else or something else
也就是说，这再次让人感到非常平静。有什么坏处吗？是的，当然有。总会有的。首先，我们需要谈谈迷信最大的坏处，那就是在不确定时期推动人们走向迷信的东西，同样也在推动人们走向阴谋论。阴谋论与心理学家所称的补偿性控制有相似之处。当事情让人感到不安全时，我们需要一个解释，我们希望有别人或别的东西
to blame the same way that we want to think that something else gives us luck. Think about time periods when superstitions and conspiracies have been the most ripe. During the Black Plague, during the Salem witch trials, after 9-11, during COVID. What is something that all those things have in common? They were very, very uncertain times. Very scary things were happening that threatened our individual sense of safety. And so people flock, once again, to things that they think are an explanation or could provide a rational explanation or could provide a rational cause and effect, even when there isn't
来承担责任，就像我们希望认为有别的东西能给我们带来好运一样。想想那些迷信和阴谋论盛行的时期。黑死病时期、塞勒姆审巫案期间、9·11事件之后、新冠疫情期间。这些事情有什么共同点？它们都是非常、非常不确定的时期。非常可怕的事情正在发生，威胁着我们对个体安全感的需求。因此，人们再次涌向那些他们认为是解释、或是能提供理性解释、或是能提供理性因果关系的事物，哪怕根本没有
any evidence for it, just because they are seeking anything. They're looking for any answer, anything that could help them, anything that could ward off a bad spirit, anything that could explain a situation so that it is more manageable to them emotionally and mentally. Superstitions can also, alongside that, become something that is very individually punishing rather than helpful when they become negative rather than positive. And I think here is a very good place to make the distinction between positive and negative superstitions because they are very different. Positive superstitions are usually organized around luck, hope, the possibility that
任何证据支撑，仅仅因为他们在寻求某种东西。他们在寻找任何答案，任何能帮助他们的东西，任何能驱除恶灵的东西，任何能解释某种情况以便他们在情感和心理上更容易掌控的东西。与此同时，迷信也可能变成一种极具个人惩罚性而非帮助性的东西，当它们变得消极而不是积极时。我认为在这里区分积极迷信和消极迷信是非常合适的，因为它们截然不同。积极的迷信通常围绕着运气、希望以及
something really good is going to happen. These are the rituals and beliefs that people use to invite success, confidence, protection in uncertain situations, good fortune. Psychologically, these superstitions do often function as a form of emotional and psychological support. In that sense, as we've explored, positive superstitions are often less about fear, the more about comfort. They help people approach challenging situations with a stronger sense of agency, a stronger sense of control, hope, structure. Negative superstitions tend to work very differently. These, These are often built less around attracting luck, more around avoiding danger, warding off bad outcomes, protecting yourself from the unknown.
好事发生的可能性展开。这些是人们用来在不确定情况下祈求成功、自信、保护和好运的仪式和信念。从心理学上讲，这些迷信确实通常起到情感和心理支持的作用。从这个意义上说，正如我们所探讨的，积极的迷信往往较少关乎恐惧，而更多关乎安慰。它们帮助人们带着更强的自主感、更强的掌控感、希望和结构去面对充满挑战的情况。消极的迷信则往往以截然不同方式运作。这些迷信往往较少围绕吸引好运，而更多围绕避开危险、驱除坏结果、保护自己免受未知侵害。
The emotional tone here is threat-based. Rather than the superstition offering encouragement, these superstitions can increase vigilance, fear, avoidance, maybe even guilt. If something bad happens and then you find out that there was a superstition all along that you shouldn't have done something, they're often bound up with the idea that something bad could happen if you get it wrong, which makes them feel psychologically heavier and more significant. It feels there's more of an urgency to perform them. That is why negative superstitions can become more time consuming or just mentally consuming compared to positive ones, because we are pulled into this preventative, anxious mindset,
这里的基调是基于威胁的。这些迷信不仅不能提供鼓励，反而会增加警惕、恐惧、回避，甚至可能是内疚。如果发生了坏事，然后你发现原来一直有一种迷信告诫你不该做某事，它们往往与“如果弄砸了就会发生坏事”的想法捆绑在一起，这使得它们在心理上感觉更沉重、更重要。人们会觉得执行这些仪式的紧迫性更高。这就是为什么与积极的迷信相比，消极的迷信会变得更耗时或更消耗心智，因为我们被卷入了一种预防性的、焦虑的心态中，
that there is something we must do to avoid bad luck. we must do so that the bad thing doesn't happen to us. Research has again found meaningful differences between people who are more likely to lean towards positive versus negative superstitions. Specifically, people who are more drawn towards negative superstitions are more likely to have severe anxiety, more likely to have a fear or what we call an intolerance for uncertainty, and typically have a higher sensitivity to threat. Similar papers have also found that negative superstitions may be more likely to be repeated
即有些事我们必须做以避免霉运。有些事我们必须做，好让坏事不降临到我们头上。研究再次发现，倾向于积极迷信的人与倾向于消极迷信的人之间存在着有意义的差异。具体来说，那些更容易被消极迷信吸引的人更有可能患有严重焦虑，更有可能有恐惧感，或者我们所说的对不确定性的不容忍，并且通常对威胁有更高的敏感度。类似的研究也发现，消极的迷信更有可能在
on an obsessive scale. Why? Simply because, again, they are threat-based. Not doing them makes us feel like something bad is going to happen. And our brain pays more attention to the possibility of bad things happening over good things happening. Hence, they capture more of our attention purely from this ancient survival mechanism point of view.
强迫性的规模上重复。为什么？很简单，因为它们同样是基于威胁的。不做这些事会让我们觉得有坏事要发生。与好事发生的可能性相比，我们的大脑会更关注坏事发生的可能性。因此，纯粹从这种古代生存机制的角度来看，它们占据了我们更多的注意力。
the greater the imagined danger, the heart of the ritual is to dismiss. And I think this is an important caveat because this is when superstitions start to more from a playful habit, a social habit, and closer to a more threat-driven coping strategy where the person is no longer asking, could this help me, but can I afford not to do this thing? So this is when we need to talk about a very, one specific mental condition in particular that does not mix very favourably with superstitious rituals. I'm going to give you a chance to guess what that may be. OCD, obsessive compulsive disorder. Superstitions quickly become very complicated and sometimes genuinely risky for people with OCD because they overlap with the same, I guess the same
想象中的危险越大，仪式的核心就是去消除它。我认为这是一个重要的警告，因为正是在这个时候，迷信开始从一种好玩的习惯、社交习惯，转变为一种更具威胁驱动力的应对策略：此时人们不再问“这能帮到我吗”，而是问“我承担不起不做这件事的后果吗”。所以，此时我们需要谈论一种非常特定的心理状况，它与迷信仪式的相容性非常糟糕。我要让你们猜猜那可能是什么。强迫症，也就是强迫性神经症。对于强迫症患者来说，迷信很快就会变得非常复杂，有时甚至真正具有风险，因为它们与
core logic that often drives obsessive behaviours. The same thing that drives people to check locks multiple times, to obsessively clean their hands, to excessively ruminate over the same thought again and again again, also drives superstitious beliefs, and that is namely magical thinking. Magical thinking sounds very fun, doesn't it? Very whimsical. Magical thinking, very magical. It's not. With OCD, it is the sense that a thought image feeling, word, small action can influence an outcome in a way that it is not
往往驱动强迫行为的相同核心逻辑重叠。驱使人们多次检查门锁、强迫性地洗手、对同一个想法反反复复过度沉思的东西，同时也驱使着迷信信仰，那就是——魔法思维。魔法思维听起来很有趣，不是吗？非常奇幻。魔法思维，非常神奇。其实不然。对于强迫症来说，这是一种感觉：一个想法、图像、感觉、词语、微小的动作可以以一种
realistically connected to. So for example, someone might fear that they, like if they don't tap a door frame exactly five times in a specific place before leaving the house, everybody and their family is going to die. They may believe that having a violent intrusive thought somehow increases the chance that that's going to come true. They're superstitious mentally. So many. So many. Somebody might believe that, you know, if they don't say a prayer a certain way or do a certain ritual a certain way, bad things will happen to them. The central idea is very similar to superstition, if not the same. It's that you may be able to influence an outcome through an unrelated act, if only you know about it, if only you are part of the group who
并不切实际相连的方式影响结果。例如，可能会有人担心，如果在离开家之前没有在特定位置精确地敲门框五次，自己和家人的所有人都将会死去。他们可能会相信，产生一个暴力的侵入性想法在某种程度上会增加该想法变成现实的可能性。他们在精神上是迷信的。太多了。真的太多了。有些人可能会相信，你知道，如果他们不以某种特定的方式祈祷或以某种特定的方式执行某个仪式，坏事就会降临到他们头上。其核心理念与迷信非常相似，甚至就是一回事。那就是：你或许能够通过一个毫不相干的行动来影响结果，只要你知道这个行动，只要你是了解
understands the superstition. And just like superstition, compulsions are often, again, attempts to cope with the discomfort, the human discomfort of not knowing. They are ways of trying to prevent harm, create certainty, neutralized danger, and therefore feel temporarily safe. The problem is, because I don't think superstitions are the problem, the problem is that in OCD, this never actually resolves the fear. It just teaches the brain that the ritual mattered, that the threat must have been real, and that uncertainty isn't tolerable. This is the interesting thing, right? You perform the ritual, you do the compulsion, the bad thing doesn't happen, but you have no way of knowing whether the bad thing wasn't going to happen all along,
这种迷信的群体中的一员。就像迷信一样，强迫行为往往也是为了应对不适感——即人类面对未知时的不适感——而做出的尝试。它们是试图防止伤害、创造确定性、消除危险并因此感到暂时安全的途径。问题在于，因为我不认为迷信本身是问题所在，问题在于在强迫症中，这实际上永远无法解决恐惧。它只是教导大脑：仪式很重要，威胁一定曾经是真实的，而且不确定性是无法容忍的。这就是有趣的地方，对吧？你执行了仪式，你进行了强迫行为，坏事没有发生，但你根本无法知道坏事是不是本来就不会发生，
because now you can't stop performing the ritual. One time there's been this coincidence that you've done this thing and the bad thing hasn't happened. In the mind of somebody with OCD, that is an amazing thing to cling on to. We're just constantly looking for anything that can tell us or give us a sense that we can control what is uncontrollable. For somebody who's just superstitious, these things are kind of fine, fun, light, enjoyable. For somebody with OCD, a superstitious belief or ritual or activity or routine,
因为现在你无法停止执行仪式了。曾经有一次，你做了这件事而坏事没有发生的巧合。在强迫症患者的心里，这是一件极其想要紧抓不放的事。我们只是在不断寻找任何能告诉我们或给我们一种感觉的东西，让我们觉得能够控制那些无法控制的事情。对于一个只是单纯迷信的人来说，这些事情其实挺不错、有趣、轻松且令人愉快的。但对于强迫症患者来说，迷信的信仰、仪式、活动或常规，
to them it is life and death. It cannot be ignored. I remember for me, I used to have to stare at the sun once a day when I was a kid to make sure it wasn't going to explode. And if I didn't look at the sun, well, everybody was cursed. Completely irrational. So irrational. But I did some very serious damage to my eyes because of that. And it's just a part of superstition and its interaction with OCD we need to be aware of. Similar process can happen with anxiety. People with high anxiety are often especially sensitive again to uncertainty, superstition, superstitions are extra appealing because they offer a quick sense of structure, something to put
对他们而言就是生死攸关的大事。这是无法被忽视的。我记得对我自己而言，小时候我曾经必须每天盯着太阳看一次，以确保它不会爆炸。如果我不看太阳，嗯，所有人都会被诅咒。完全不合逻辑。极其不理性。但正因为如此，我对自己的眼睛造成了一些非常严重的伤害。这就是迷信及其与强迫症相互作用的一个方面，我们需要对此有所认识。焦虑也会发生类似的过程。高度焦虑的人往往再次对不确定性特别敏感，迷信、迷信对他们有着额外的吸引力，因为它们提供了一种快速的结构感，提供了一件他们现在就能付诸行动的事情。
into action that they can do right now. Instead of sitting with the distress of not knowing, instead of seeing how things may play out, the anxious mind gets to do something. So then in that moment, yeah, the superstition, the belief, the ritual does reduce the intensity of the anxiety. That makes it more likely to be repeated, but you never get to see what's on the other side of if you didn't perform the superstition. Even if somebody doesn't, even if they don't rationally think that this ritual is doing anything, it becomes what we call a maladaptive coping mechanism. So whilst superstition and OCD or anxiety related behaviors are not the same thing, they do rest on similar psychological foundations. One of the clearest, clearest differences
焦虑的心态不用去面对“不知道”带来的痛苦，不用去看着事情如何发展，而是能做点什么。所以在那个时刻，是的，迷信、信仰、仪式确实降低了焦虑的强度。这使得它更有可能被重复，但你永远无法看到如果你没有执行迷信，另一边会是什么样子。即使某人并没有、即使他们在理性上不认为这个仪式在起任何作用，它也变成了我们所说的适应不良的应对机制。因此，虽然迷信与强迫症或焦虑相关的行为并非同一事物，但它们确实建立在相似的心理基础之上。最清晰、最明显的区别之一，
and ways for you to tell if it's something you're worried about is how the behavior feels. If the behavior is flexible, occasional, more lighthearted than it is distressing, it's more likely to be an ordinary ritual or an ordinary superstition. But if it starts to feel rigid, urgent, exhausting, or impossible to resist, if you feel like you have to do it, that may be a sign that something more than everyday superstition is going on. The same is true if the ritual keeps expanding. If one rule turns into many or if the relief never really lasts for that long, that is a sign that your superstition is becoming its own unmanageable beast.
也是辨别这是否是你所担忧的事情的方法，在于这种行为给人的感觉。如果这种行为是灵活的、偶尔为之的、与其说是痛苦不如说是轻松的，那么它更有可能是一种普通的仪式或普通的迷信。但如果它开始变得死板、急迫、令人筋疲力尽或无法抗拒，如果你觉得自己不得不做，这可能是一个迹象，表明除了日常迷信之外，有更严重的事情正在发生。如果仪式不断扩大，情况也是如此。如果一条规则变成许多条，或者如果这种解脱感从未真正持续太久，那就是你的迷信正在变成它自己的一个无法掌控的怪物的迹象。
And if that's the case, like that's when you do need professional help. Because it is very much manageable. That's the thing. Superstitions or magical thinking is manageable. You just need somebody who can guide you through it. And again, not all superstitions are going to turn out that way. Not all people who are superstitious have OCD or have a need. intense anxiety. It is just one link and one relationship that is just important to be aware of.
如果真是这样，那就是你需要寻求专业帮助的时候了。因为这完全是可以控制的。事情就是这样。迷信或魔法思维是可以控制的。你只需要一个能引导你度过难关的人。再说一次，并非所有的迷信最终都会演变成那样。并非所有迷信的人都有强迫症或强烈的焦虑。这只是一个需要我们加以注意的联系和关系。
Okay, we are going to take one more short break, but when we return, let's go back towards the positives of superstition and rituals and talk about why having superstitions and habits maybe is important in our 20s. Maybe is something that more of us should be looking to adopt. Stay with us. Toronto. Pride is an opportunity for you to create your own space, to celebrate your existence. Iheart Radio is proud to be an official sponsor of Pride Toronto Festival and we won't stop. Celebrate Pride. Turn up the love and listen to IHeart Pride Canada.
好了，我们还要进行短暂的休息，但当我们回来时，让我们重新探讨迷信和仪式的积极面，并讨论为什么在二十多岁时拥有迷信和习惯或许很重要。这或许是我们当中更多人应该考虑去采纳的东西。请继续收听。多伦多自豪节为你提供了一个创造属于你自己的空间、庆祝你存在的机会。IHeart Radio很荣幸能成为多伦多自豪节的官方赞助商，并且我们不会停下脚步。庆祝自豪节。点燃爱意，收听IHeart Pride Canada。
Your 24-7 radio stream and the only playlist you need for your Toronto Pride celebrations. Pride is so great because it gives a whole bunch of people this visibility that they've never had before. We have a ton to celebrate Toronto. Happy Pride. IHeart Radio. In the moment, it felt like it was going on forever. I didn't think I was going to live. I was terrified.
你的24/7全天候无线电广播，也是你多伦多自豪节庆祝活动唯一需要的播放列表。自豪节之所以如此伟大，是因为它让一大群人获得了前所未有的可见度。多伦多，我们有太多值得庆祝的事情。节日快乐。IHeart Radio。那一刻，感觉像是过了一个世纪。我以为自己活不成了。我吓坏了。
There was no anything inside those eyes. They turned black. It scared the hell out of me. That was your first murder case? Yes, sir. Fear to say this was the biggest case of your career? Yes, sir. Rape a murder for a young 12-year-old child.
那些眼睛里没有任何东西。它们变得漆黑。这把我吓了个半死。那是你的第一起谋杀案吗？是的，先生。可以说这是你职业生涯中最大的案件吗？是的，先生。针对一个12岁年轻孩子的强奸谋杀案。
She's as bad as it gets. I would think so. People wake up. I'm the one that saw the murder take place. by crevette and de pippo. Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse, appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum. I said, I'm not guilty.
她坏到了极点。我想是的。人们醒醒吧。我才是亲眼目睹这起谋杀案发生的人。作者：克雷维特和德皮波。安东尼·德皮波毫无悔意，在被判处最高刑罚后显得镇定自若。我说，我没有罪。
I'll take it to the grief. Listen to the devil's quarry on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. And to hear the Devil's Quarry ad free with exclusive content, subscribe to Lobba for Good Plus on Apple Podcasts. Hey, I'm Hoda Kotby, host of the podcast, Joy 101, Hoda Kotby. Together, we're going to have meaningful conversations with the world's most fascinating people, like when actress Olivia Munn shared how she overcame fierce health challenges.
我要把它带进坟墓里。在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《恶魔采石场》。要在苹果播客上收听无广告且包含独家内容的《恶魔采石场》，请订阅Lobba for Good Plus。嘿，我是霍达·科特比，播客《Joy 101, Hoda Kotby》的主持人。我们将与世界上最迷人的人物进行有意义的对话，例如当女演员奥利维亚·穆恩分享她是如何克服严峻的健康挑战时。
I've gone through breast cancer and then helped my mother through breast cancer, and that was more difficult. There's a lot of people who understand postpartner depression. I was not prepared for postpartum anxiety. Listen to Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Everyone star is Jeterito Hernandez. Everyone sees me as a football player, but before anything else, I'm human. Every single day, I'm still learning how to live with problems, mistakes, relationships, emotions ever since I was born.
我经历过乳腺癌，然后又帮助我母亲度过乳腺癌，那更加困难。有很多人理解产后抑郁症。但我并没有为产后焦虑做好准备。在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听由霍达·科特比主持的《Joy 101》。每一个球星都是小豌豆埃尔南德斯。每个人都视我为一个足球运动员，但在其他任何事情之前，我都只是个人。每一天，我仍在学习如何与问题、错误、人际关系、情绪共存，自从我出生以来便是如此。
And I still have so many questions. Where do we come from? What happens after death? How do you deal with cancellation? Cristiano or Messi? Do aliens exist? What is love? Real Madrid or Varsa?
而我仍然有这么多的疑问。我们从哪里来？死后会发生什么？你如何应对取消文化？C罗还是梅西？真的有外星人吗？什么是爱？皇家马德里还是巴塞罗那？
From every day and ordinary to the deep and extraordinary. This isn't a normal podcast. Everything here is spontaneous, real and genuine. This podcast is like a deep talk with your closest friends, where vulnerability comes out. Conspiracy theories end up on the table, and goals and lessons are shared. All in this life has a order perfect and everything is just.
从日常与平凡到深邃与非凡。这不是一个普通的播客。这里的一切都是自发的、真实的、真诚的。这个播客就像是与你最亲密的朋友进行的一次深入交谈，脆弱感流露出来。阴谋论最终被摆上台面，目标和人生教训得以分享。生命中的一切都有完美的秩序，一切都是公正的。
Wait me, I'm going to pressur me, but me will go to be able to be able to be connect. The Chicharito. Oh, Javier El Chicholito, and together with IHard Radio, we're going to make the ordinary, extraordinary. Stay close. It is a carac. Wow.
等等我，我要给自己施加压力，但我要能够去连接。小豌豆奇查里托。哦，哈维尔·埃尔·奇查里托，我们将与IHard Radio一起，将平凡化为非凡。敬请关注。这是一个特质。哇。
Listen to learning to be human on AHA Radio. Apple Podcast or wherever you get your podcast. Keith Giamanka seemed like a mild-mannered suburban dad, but secretly, he became someone else, a master of disguise who went on a crime spree. At the time, did it seem like a crazy idea? It seemed very crazy, but I felt so desperate that I felt it was the quickest, easiest way out.
在AHA Radio、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《学习做人》。基思·贾曼卡看起来像是一个温和的郊区父亲，但暗地里，他变成了另一个人，一个伪装大师，并开始了一场犯罪狂潮。当时，这看起来像是一个疯狂的想法吗？这看起来非常疯狂，但我感到如此绝望，以至于我觉得这是最快、最简单的出路。
Did you allow yourself to think about how it could go wrong on what that might look like. No, I didn't want to manifest that. I was trying to manifest success. Every family has its secrets. But what happens when you discover that your dad has been living a double life? That is not the look of an innocent man. This is going to change my life and my family dynamic forever, because everything that had
你有没有让自己去想过事情会如何出错，以及那可能会是什么样子。不，我不想让这种想法成真。我试图让成功成为现实。每个家庭都有秘密。但是，当你发现你的父亲过着双重生活时，会发生什么？那看起来可不是一个无辜之人的样子。这永远改变了我和我家人的生活轨迹，因为此前存在于我现实中的一切
existed prior in my reality is now untrue. Listen to Deep Cover the Family Man on the iHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I think we all need more rituals. Superstitious or not. A hill I will die on. Humanity is sadder and less connected because we no longer have the same spiritual practices we're used to. Now let me say this, because people always get mad when I talk about the importance of spirituality. But there are some very, very scary, sad, destructive parts about religion.
现在都变得不真实了。在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《深度卧底：居家男人》。我认为我们都需要更多的仪式。无论是迷信还是其他。这是一个我至死都要捍卫的观点。人类变得更加悲伤、联系更加稀疏，因为我们不再拥有我们习惯的那些相同的精神实践。现在让我这么说，因为每当我谈到灵性的重要性时，人们总是会生气。但宗教中确实有一些非常、非常可怕、悲伤、具破坏性的部分。
No denying religion has a very terrible history for many people. But one thing most major religions did get right was that humans feel better when they have a practice like prayer, when they have a practice like visiting an altar, like saying grace, specific traditions they can return to. It provides a much-needed center for people. It provides, once more, something they can control when life is on. certain. So when we talk about why superstitions and rituals matter so much, especially in our 20s, I think the answer is because this is the decade where we are most often asked to create stability without actually being given very much of it externally. We are in probably peak
不可否认，对许多人来说，宗教有着一段非常糟糕的历史。但大多数主要宗教做对的一件事是，人类在拥有祈祷这样的实践时，在拥有诸如拜访祭坛、做餐前祈祷这样的实践、以及可以回归的特定传统时，感觉会更好。它为人们提供了一个急需的精神中心。当生活充满不确定性时，它再次提供了一种他们可以控制的东西。因此，当我们谈论为什么迷信和仪式如此重要，尤其是在我们的二十多岁时，我认为答案是：因为这是我们最常被要求创造稳定感、而实际上外界并没有给予我们太多稳定感的十年。我们现在可能正处于
uncertainty times right now. Your 20s are just full of just everything could go wrong, everything may be going wrong. And you're just trying to figure it out. You're trying to figure out what you actually care about. You're trying to make choices without complete information. You're trying to build a life whilst probably still grieving the life you had only a few years ago. You are changing at such a rapid rate. You literally, some days you think you know everything about yourself. The next day you know absolutely nothing. Some days you love your friends. The next days you feel lonely. Some days you feel great about your career the next day. You have no clue how you're going to do this for the rest of your life. This is an incredibly psychologically intense thing to live through for anybody.
不确定性的巅峰时期。你的二十多岁简直充满了各种可能出错的事情，一切都可能正在出错。而你只是在努力弄清楚这一切。你试图弄清楚你真正在乎的是什么。你试图在信息不完整的情况下做出选择。你试图建立生活，同时可能还在为几年前才拥有的生活感到哀伤。你以如此迅猛的速度在改变。字面意义上，有些天你觉得自己了解关于自己的一切。第二天你却对一无所知。有些天你爱你的朋友。接下来的几天你感到孤独。有些天你对自己的职业感觉良好，第二天你又毫无头绪，不知道自己接下来的一生要怎么过。对任何人来说，经历这样一段在心理上极其剧烈的生活都是非常不容易的。
Rituals and superstitions become important during this time because, much like the spiritual rituals we spoke about before, they become this grounding force to return to. They're always going to be there. They are stable. They are consistent. Wearing the same earrings to every job interview. Wearing red on your first dates. Saying a mantra to yourself every morning before you walk out the door.
仪式和迷信在这个时期变得重要是因为，就像我们之前谈到的精神仪式一样，它们变成了回归的这种根基力量。它们将永远存在。它们是稳定的。它们是一致的。每次去面试都穿同一副耳环。第一次约会时穿红色衣服。每天出门前在心里对自己念一句咒语。
watching the same movie every year on your birthday to ensure that you have good luck for the year ahead is a powerful form of uncertainty management in an uncertain time, even if it's a very, very small thing to do. Here are some other superstitions, superstitious of rituals, I should say, that you guys provided that I think maybe something you want to consider doing in your life. You guys, the listeners, wrote in with these, thank you for your contributions. let me read some of them out. Okay, are you guys ready?
每年生日看同一部电影以确保自己在接下来的一年里有好运，在不确定的时期里，这是管理不确定性的一种强大形式，哪怕这只是一件非常、非常小的事情。以下是你们提供的其他一些迷信或仪式，我应该这么说，我认为这可能是你想考虑在生活中做的事情。听众朋友们，你们写信提供了这些，感谢你们的贡献。让我读出其中的一些。好吧，你们准备好了吗？
Always sitting in the same seat at the movie cinema. Love that one. This one comes from Maggie. Keeping every single birthday card you receive because throwing them out would mean such would signify that you want that relationship with that person to end. I will be doing that one.
在电影院里总是坐在同一个座位上。喜欢这个。这个来自玛吉。保留你收到的每一张生日贺卡，因为把它们扔掉就意味着你希望与那个人的关系结束。我一定会做这个。
Again, superstitious. I want my relationships to be good and healthy. That seems like a smart way to do it. This person says, I cut my hair off after making a big, decision to signify such prove to the universe, God, the world question mark, that I'm serious about it. Not telling anyone good news until it absolutely is confirmed. I do this one. My mom was such a big believer in this when we were growing up, so I will continue to do this. I reread old
再说一次，这是迷信。我希望自己的人际关系好而且健康。这似乎是一个明智的做法。这个人说，在做了一个重大决定后我剪掉了头发，以向宇宙、上帝、世界（问号）证明我是认真的。在绝对确认之前不把好消息告诉任何人。我就会这样做。我妈妈在我们长大的时候非常坚信这一点，所以我将继续这样做。我重新阅读旧的
journals every single new year so that I don't have to repeat the same lessons twice. Watching the sunrise every year on my birthday. I love this one. You guys know, I do this, such a version of this. Always donating the first $10 of every paycheck to show abundance and that I am protected and supported enough by the universe that I can give money away. Having cold showers on the first day of every single month in brackets, I have never missed a month for five years. Crazy. Another one that I love. My friend Erica actually keeps wine bottles from important meals in her life as a way to just kind of show gratitude. And I don't know why she does it.
日记每一个新年，这样我就不用把同样的教训重复两遍。每年生日看日出。我喜欢这个。大家知道的，我做过这个，这是它的一种版本。总是把每笔工资的前10美元捐出去，以展现丰盛，以及我受到宇宙的充分保护和支持，我可以把钱施舍出去。每个月的第一天洗冷水澡（括号内：我已经连续五年每个月都没有间断过）。太疯狂了。我喜欢的另一个。我的朋友埃里卡实际上把她生命中重要聚餐的酒瓶保留下来，作为一种表达感激的方式。我不知道她为什么要这么做。
I think it's like a superstition that like if she doesn't keep these bottles, it shows that she's not grateful and she won't have more nights like that. So it's like a gratitude practice of like collecting and a gratitude practice of keeping mementos. Those are just some examples that you guys sent in. Sometimes again, like I love these. They're not always about superstition. then are always about luck. I think a lot of them are about faith and they're about repetition
我想这就像是一种迷信，如果她不保留这些瓶子，就表明她不知感恩，也不会再有那样的夜晚了。所以这就像是一个收集的感恩练习，也是一个保留纪念物的感恩练习。这些只是你们发来的一些例子。有时候，我再次强调，我喜欢这些。它们并不总是关于迷信。它们也不总是关于运气。我认为它们很多是关于信仰，是关于重复
and they're about control. Again, not necessarily religious faith, but faith in the broader sense, faith that this moment we're in means something, that you can do hard things, that you are protected in some small way, that hope is still allowed, that there is a meaning in the mystery of life, and that you are in control, that you get to come back to the things that are important. to you and you have a way of, I guess, managing the unexpected. I think there's something very beautiful about this that we kind of need now more than ever, yes, during our 20s, but also just in this weird time of humanity. We talk about superstition as if it's silly or embarrassing or something to grow out of. But I do think a lot of the time, again, thinking of those examples,
并且它们是关于控制的。再次说明，不一定是宗教信仰，而是更广泛意义上的信仰，相信我们所处的这个时刻有意义，相信你能做困难的事，相信你在某种程度上受到了保护，相信希望依然被允许，相信生命的神秘之中自有意义，并且相信你是处于控制之中的，你有办法回归到对你重要的事情上，并且你有一种方法，我猜，去应付那些意料之外的事。我认为这里面有一种非常美好的东西，我们现在比以往任何时候都更需要它，是的，在我们二十多岁时，但也正是在人类这段奇怪的时期。我们谈论迷信时，好像它很傻、很尴尬或是某种应该随着长大而抛弃的东西。但我确实认为很多时候，再次想想那些例子，
what we are really doing is creating our own magic, creating our own alchemy. We are taking an ordinary moment, an ordinary object, an ordinary routine, and saying, this matters to me, therefore it must matter full stop. This helps me. This makes me feel brave. This gives me a small point of steadiness. It doesn't matter if it does or doesn't based on the evidence. It's important to me. And studies have shown that people who do have rituals, who do have routine, who do have superstitions, a belief system, grounding habits are happier, they're more well adjusted, and ultimately they feel more capable of handling difficult things because they have coping measures, because they have something that redefines their self-efficacy.
我们真正做的是创造我们自己的魔法，创造我们自己的炼金术。我们将一个普通的时刻、一个普通的物件、一个普通的日常常规拿来，然后说：这对我来说很重要，因此它必须完全重要。这能帮助我。这让我感到勇敢。这给了我一个小小的坚定点。根据证据来看，它起不起作用并不重要。它对我很重要。研究表明，那些确实拥有仪式、确实拥有日常常规、确实拥有迷信、一个信仰体系以及根基习惯的人会更快乐，他们适应得更好，最终他们会觉得自己更有能力处理困难的事情，因为他们有应对的措施，因为他们有能够重新定义自我效能感的东西。
That is one of the most human things about us. We are actually not just creatures of logic. We are creatures of meaning. It doesn't matter that these things are irrational. It's why we make art. It's why we sing songs. It's why we are superstitious. It's why superstitions show up in every single,
那是我们身上最具有人性的东西之一。实际上，我们不仅仅是逻辑的产物。我们是意义的产物。这些事情不合逻辑并不重要。这就是我们为什么要创作艺术。这就是为什么要唱歌。这就是为什么我们会迷信。这就是为什么迷信会出现在世界上每一个
culture in the world, why they are part of humanity. We want to believe in something bigger, and we want to believe that there is something significant in the small things that we do. That is psychologically important in a way that doesn't always make sense, but just happens to be true. So that is the psychology of superstition. I hope you enjoy this episode. As a little summary before I say goodbye to you, superstition is in every single culture in the world because it says something really, really important about our emotional and psychological state as humans, which is that we like order, we like structure, we like feeling that we are in control. When we are faced with uncertain things, believing that a four-leaf clover gives you good
文化中，为什么它们是人类的一部分。我们想要相信更伟大的事物，我们想要相信我们所做的微小事情中具有重大意义。这在心理上是重要的，虽然有时说不通，但它偏偏就是真的。这就是迷信的心理学。希望你们喜欢这一集。在我向你们道别前作个小结：迷信存在于世界的每一种文化中，因为它非常真切地说明了我们作为人类的情感和心理状态，那就是我们喜欢秩序，我们喜欢结构，我们喜欢那种觉得自己能够掌控一切的感觉。当我们面临不确定的事情时，相信四叶草能给你带来好运，
luck, even though it's just a clover, believing that knocking on wood somehow protects you, even though there's no science to that, it's anxiety management, it's fear management, it's emotional regulation and I think one that is overlooked far too often. Superstitions definitely can go a little bit off the rails, especially when they get mixed up in conspiracy theories and in OCD and anxiety, but ultimately they are very, very valuable. And if they are not hurting anybody, there is probably a chance that they are helping you because it brings back a sense of agency. It means that you feel, I don't know,
哪怕它只是一株三叶草；相信敲木头能在某种程度上保护你，哪怕这没有任何科学依据——这是焦虑的管理，这是恐惧的管理，这是情绪的调节，我认为这是一个常常被忽视的调节。迷信确实有时会有点失控，特别是当它们与阴谋论、强迫症和焦虑混合在一起时，但归根结底它们是非常、非常有价值的。如果它们没有伤害任何人，那么大概率它们是在帮助你，因为这带回了一种自主感。这意味着你感到，怎么说呢，
safe enough to actually do something rather than nothing, and therefore does create self-fulfilling prophecies. As we've seen from these examples, it does end up changing outcomes for people, not because what they did actually mattered, but because what it made them feel and what it then allowed them to do. So there we go. The psychology of superstition. I hope you enjoy this episode. If you have made it this far and you were listening on Spotify, leave a little comment down below. what is a superstitious belief that you have? I was just saying to a friend of mine, my belief, and this is like totally not related to my life right now, people are going to be like, oh my God, she's going to have a baby. But no, I really believe that before, like, if you're
足够安全去真正做点什么，而不是无所事事，因此这确实创造了自正如我们从这些例子中所看到的，它最终确实改变了人们的结果，不是因为他们做的事真的很重要，而是因为这让他们有了怎样的感受，进而让他们能够去做什么。好了，这就是迷信的心理学。希望你们喜欢这一集。如果你听到了这里并且你正在Spotify上收听，请在下方留下一个小评论：你有什么迷信的信念吗？我刚刚还在对我的朋友说，我的信念——这跟我目前的生活完全没有关系，人们可能会觉得，天哪，她要生孩子了——但不是的，我真的相信，在……如果你
pregnant slash expecting a child, you should not bring any like baby stroller, baby crib into the house before the child is born. Don't know why, but I am so superstitious about it. And I think when I have kids, I will not be doing that. I think it's something like an old wives tale that my mom told me. So share yours down below. Thank you as always to our amazing researcher Libby Kobe for her assistance and help with this episode. You can also watch this episode and many others on Netflix. Check it out. Go have a look. It's really cool. You can follow us on Substack. You can also follow us on Instagram if you want more visual summaries of episodes just like this one. There's all the stuff in the description, including some of our favorite
怀孕/期待一个孩子之前，你不应该在孩子出生前把任何婴儿推车、婴儿床搬进家里。不知道为什么，但我对此迷信得不行。我想等我有孩子的时候，我不会这么做。我觉得这就像是我妈妈告诉我的一则老妇奇谈。所以请在下方分享你们的看法吧。一如既往地感谢我们出色的研究员莉比·科比（Libby Kobe）对本集节目的协助。你也可以在Netflix上观看这一集以及许多其他剧集。去看看吧。去看一看。真的非常酷。你可以在Substack上关注我们。如果你想要更多像这样的一集节目的视觉总结，也可以在Instagram上关注我们。描述栏里有所有的东西，包括我们这一集最喜欢的一些
sources from this episode so go check it out but with all that in mind be safe be kind be a little bit superstitious and be gentle to yourself we will talk very very soon there was no anything inside those eyes they turned black it scared the hell out of me people wake up i'm the one that saw the murder take place by crevette and de pippo anthony de pippo showed no signs of remorse a appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum. I said, I'm not guilty. I'll take it to the grave. Listen to the devil's quarry in the Bone Valley Feed on the IHeart Radio app. Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
来源，所以去看看吧。但考虑到所有这些，保持安全、保持善良、稍微带点迷信色彩，并对你自己温柔一点。我们很快就会再聊。那些眼睛里没有任何东西。它们变得漆黑。这把我吓了个半死。人们醒醒吧。我才是亲眼目睹这起谋杀案发生的人。作者：克雷维特和德皮波。安东尼·德皮波毫无悔意，在被判处最高刑罚后显得镇定自若。我说，我没有罪。我要把它带进坟墓里。在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《骨谷源流》中的《恶魔采石场》。
Joy is essential, and it's also elusive, but now, there's a new and exciting way to start your journey toward a more joyful existence, Joy 101. It's a new podcast hosted by me, Hoda Kotby. If you're craving inspiration to maximize your joy, tune into these candid, uplifting, and moving on-air chats. Open your free IHeart Radio app. Search Joy 101 and listen now. Joy 101 with Hoda Kotfi is presented by CVS.
快乐至关重要，它也难以捉摸，但现在，有一个激动人心的新方法可以开启你迈向更快乐生活的新旅程——《Joy 101》。这是一个由我霍达·科特比主持的新播客。如果你渴望获得灵感来最大化你的快乐，请收听这些坦诚、振奋人心且感人的空中闲聊。打开你免费的IHeart Radio应用程序。搜索《Joy 101》并立即收听。由CVS呈现的霍达·科特比主持的《Joy 101》。
Everyone sees me as a football player, but before anything else, I'm human. Every single day I'm still learning how to live with problems, mistakes, relationships, emotions, ever since I was born. This isn't a normal podcast. Everything here is a spontaneous, and genuine, just honest conversations about what it means to be alive. I'm Javier Tchariot Hernandez and listen to Learning to Be Human on IHard Radio, Apple Podcasts,
每个人都视我为一个足球运动员，但在其他任何事情之前，我都只是个人。每一天，我仍在学习如何与问题、错误、人际关系、情绪共存，自从我出生以来便是如此。这不是一个普通的播客。这里的一切都是自发的、真实的，只是一些关于生存意味着什么的诚实对话。我是哈维尔·奇查里托·埃尔南德斯，在IHard Radio、苹果播客上收听《学习做人》，
or whatever you get your podcast. Your husband is not who you think he is. Your body is not what you thought it was. Your identity is formed by a secret history. I'm Danny Shapiro. And these are just a few of the stunning stories I'll be exploring on the 14th season of Family Secrets. He kind of shoved me out of the way and said, move. And he went out the front door and he jumped in a car and drove off.
或者在您获取播客的任何地方收听。你的丈夫并不是你认为的那样。你的身体也并非你想象的那样。你的身份是由一段秘密历史塑造的。我是丹尼·夏皮罗。这些只是我将在《家庭秘密》第十四季中探讨的几个惊人故事。他把我推开，说，让开。然后他走到前门，跳上一辆车开走了。
And that was the last time I saw him. Listen to season 14 of Family Secrets on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Every family has its secrets. But what happens when you discover that your dad has been living a double life? That is not the look of an innocent man. Is everyone lying to me about who they are? I felt such desperation. I felt it was what I had to do.
那是我最后一次见到他。在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《家庭秘密》第十四季。每个家庭都有秘密。但是，当你发现你的父亲过着双重生活时，会发生什么？那看起来可不是一个无辜之人的样子。难道每个人都在对我撒谎，隐瞒他们是谁吗？我感到如此绝望。我觉得这是我不得不做的事。
Listen to deep cover the family man on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed Human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《深度卧底：居家男人》。这是一个IHeart播客。保证真人。本集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何句子即可发表评论。